yo this wack 100 check me out on the
bootleg care podcast
cause i'm gonna be talking that [ __ ]
blackhead podcast special guest man my
guy whack 100 is here
yo man you put that [ __ ] duct tape on
your mouth kev i don't like that [ __ ]
bro you know man
[Laughter]
find the [ __ ] did that day it's
a problem whack
um you know it's crazy because i it's
you know i've been wanting to get you on
the podcast for a while yeah i know
so i know that there's some some [ __ ]
going on on the internet right now but i
want you to know that's not why you're
here we're going to talk about it ain't
tripping
but you know what it is yeah i've been
wanting to have you on here for a long
time what i want to start is
give me what you're like i feel like
there's many misconceptions about whack
yeah well you know i'm i'm kind of who
who i want you to know depending on who
you are
you know like with you every time it's a
phone call it always been
hey kev i got something for you can i
you know what i'm saying
you know because i really see the future
in you i don't you know i think
you're on your eyes you i haven't even
got nowhere near to what
you know where you're going to become
and i've always been of uh big on
relationships
that's what i'm saying i've always been
big on you know if you in a position to
do something for somebody do it
and don't keep count with it you know
what i mean well you know you're uh
a lot of people don't know this but
you're one of the reasons i got hired in
l.a man exactly
i was in tampa and you put the word in
yeah i called i was in the meeting and
there was
doc winters and everybody that was uh
put you know putting together the
structure
of uh the real 923 yeah it even came and
i was like yo
you know what i mean you know our boy
bootleg we [ __ ] with him everybody [ __ ]
when he be fit
you know what i mean and [ __ ] you know
doc i put you on line with him and
yeah you know it's crazy yeah they could
at the time they couldn't hire me
because i was under contract but it
ended up working out yeah it was on the
contract at the time but
you know that seed was planning i
appreciate that you did
was already doing do you remember when i
was in tampa you threatened to kill me
no about what what happened i gotta
refresh i gotta refresh your memory on
this
this one remember coming through no no
no no no it was over the phone
so let me this is this whenever people
tell me crazy wack stories i'm like i
got
one and then this was after i was behind
a game or something
so let me tell you what happened i was
out with dante from e1 one night
oh yeah dante be [ __ ] around so what
happened was
dante's telling me about this meek mill
recovery game right
and he's like yo this shit's about to be
crazy whatever coming out through e1 i'm
like cool
maybe two hours later we're still out i
think we're out at the club or something
some twitter page tweets me at bootleg
kev
bran a leaked brand new game meek mill
record with a link
i show it to dante i say yo there's this
this page is tweeting every dj in the
country right
i'm like is this it he's like yeah
screenshot that so i can send it to
whack
so he screenshot it and sent it to you
and it's and if you read it out loud it
said
at bootleg have leaked brand new game
meek mill song oh [ __ ]
so the next day i get a call from you
saying that i leaked your [ __ ]
and i'm like bro whack i was with dante
last night and
that was the one time i got a bad [ __ ]
roll down here i must have got a call
from gang
i don't know but i was like that page is
tweeting everybody
like i don't know everybody gotta
understand like i probably understand
like 30 percent of social media yeah
that was the one you know what i'm
saying that was my one time where i saw
that
i'm still learning [ __ ] yeah like you
know what i mean i'm still learning how
to
hit a hack i could how to research how
to i got to ask my kids you know what
what's this well then what dante did
like because i was like dante you gotta
fix this bro like i was with him like
he's dante's in tablet this is the
[ __ ] song
yeah it was leaked but i didn't leak it
it was some you know what i really
i started finding out a lot of the
labels was doing back then
is um they were servicing the [ __ ]
overseas
and the overseas platform was always 24
hours
they had our platform so what happened
is
once bloggers know that they're reaching
over there grabbing it and then it's
over here because a lot of people don't
know itunes platform overseas
it's totally different than ours over
here it's a whole nother game it's a
whole nother game
but you know what i didn't you know
what's crazy i bet you next time i talk
to you
it was like we i was like it was like it
never happened because you know why this
is i'm glad you said that yeah
because the [ __ ] wasn't personal was
business that's fair
like i didn't i it wasn't a thing at
bootleg
cab it was like this is the situation
this who did it address them so
probably when i called you the next time
it was probably surprising it was like
it was like nothing ever happened
because i didn't it wasn't in my mind it
wasn't
problem with bootleg cab it was problem
right here behind door number one
got you you know what i'm saying so
that's probably what that was cause
it's always been love with you you
always know for sure
when cool and you know um you know you
really are part of our coach
our culture i appreciate everybody in
the part of our culture all the dj's
that are part of our culture
people that you know you're going to see
all the time
and not just see because you got to hit
record you know you're going to see
kevin you know i went to
put up on jim jones cav want to say you
know what i'm saying you're going to see
kev out you're gonna see him so well i
just ran into uh a big youth screening
uh
yeah at mountains i didn't see you twice
in the last couple weeks that's facts
yeah
melrose yeah yeah vic you screaming yeah
yeah
uh jim jones and french song you know
what i mean but you know you
you know you're gonna pull up that's why
you and dj head made it such a great duo
because
he the same way you're gonna see him
he's not yeah yeah for sure
we got some new [ __ ] pull up he's
pulling up to the studio camden been in
there with
30 wolves yeah he don't get you know
what i'm saying he gonna pull up by
himself
come in and that's what where the [ __ ]
are you from anyway phoenix man
yeah yeah that's why i always get
phoenix i've been moving around though
you know the radio lights got the
station down there what's the homie name
always
power 98.3 the homie if you used to fly
back to new mexico to go home
mikey fuentes yeah there you go mikey
mikey's still down there nah he's in
boise
he's you got boise yeah got you yeah
that's family man shout out to mikey
points but
yeah phoenix here what's up man let's
get to the juicy
well listen let's just get out let's get
that out of the way all right man listen
right now people
you you viral right now when is this
song coming out
they mixing that [ __ ] down right now so
i got my producer you know i'm saying uh
swiss cheese yeah so let's talk about
this man uh you know what
i what i what i it's entertaining to me
that at times
you will speak on [ __ ] that don't got
nothing to do with you but it stirs up a
lot of [ __ ]
you know what i i i really wasn't gonna
say nothing at first right
talking about the meek mill situation
yeah but see what i don't like i'm gonna
call it spade a spade right
whether it's in favor of me or or not
right and it's like
what i've been noticing about this
industry is that
people tend because of who you are
they sweep [ __ ] under the rug but if the
same for somebody else committed the
same act
they're crucified and i believe you know
hey
everybody got to be held accountable for
what they do
you know what i mean like for instance
um you know i got mixed feelings about
this little kid
you know i mean because yeah he did what
he did but on this one
six nine yeah on the same note he
shouldn't have never been in position to
do what he did
you know i mean you know this thing we
got in the streets right
it ain't for everybody and it's just not
a free fall it ain't like [ __ ] uh
magic mountain
you show up buy a ticket and get in
there's certain things you got to go
through certain things you got that has
to be proven
before somebody is is allowed to come in
you know and the fact that they allowed
him to come in is with
you know him being inside of it is what
gave him
information you know they chose to bring
him into it once you brought him in and
you allowed him to see certain things
you're discussing certain things
you know what i mean um he shouldn't
have never
had the information that he had when he
got put up under that light
you know what i mean everything ain't
for everybody and and i really think he
was
he was in uh he was in character the
whole time he was using the block boy
street cred
you know everything about the kid
besides what he said he was
no just you know the you know the um the
gay community
has adopted the rainbow as um
as pretty much yeah they're flagged
right the kid got rainbow head
i mean we do the bath on everything
about the kid it totally defines
you know what they allowed him to do you
know what i mean so
um i already know what they did they do
what they always do they press play on
the kid
they let the kid hear things that was
going on and you know behind his back
and because
he don't fall up under that script he
don't fall up
under that real cold no matter i can hit
somebody can press play
and show me a dude running a train on my
wife and and
this to do to kill my brother and this
this this
the code say whatever it is is going on
i got to deal with that how i got to
deal with that i don't deal with that
through the law
i got to keep my mouth shut when i get
it you got to handle it yeah the way you
handle it
exactly but again that's me and and i
think that they put this kid in the
situation
that he shouldn't have been in and what
he did was
he just went back to who he really was
he took the costume off
so it's i got mixed emotions of what we
call this kid to snitch
because i i believe uh civilians don't
snitch they tell the truth
so we're looking i mean they don't
snitch they tell the truth
they put this dude in this situation
that he shouldn't have been in
right so he did what he did and i
believe even right now today
uh he uses what he does
as a marketing tool because he has no
obligation
to the politics of the streets
he has none he don't care how it goes
he's just you know a little kid
playing and doodling and it's and he
it's allowed they're allowing it to
happen you know what i mean
you know i think he got a death wish i
think he want to go all the water one
day
you know it's funny because because
that's what i
would like me and head always have these
discussions about like that that word
snitching right
and it applies it could never be a
snitch because
because we are not in that world my son
my son is not a gang member
right he's a civilian he's taught to
tell the truth
civilians and people who live by that
code are
total different things you can't like
even with this music game right and i
got to tell people right
when they say yo whack man on some real
g [ __ ] man these [ __ ] djs
[ __ ] and these bills
they ain't keep it real look at this
this baggy [ __ ] they doing all this [ __ ]
i'm like yo bro check this out
can they bring the things they do on the
building to the projects
hell no i said because it's rules and
regulations that we created in the
projects right
okay great once upon a time guys like
you and guys like me we weren't allowed
in the building
so if you think that you're gonna go in
the building and force those people that
been conducting business the way they've
been conducting business
for 50 60 70 years to adapt to
our way of conducting business you sadly
mistaken it ain't gonna work like that
you gotta find equal medium
you know the industry is a [ __ ] it's
a [ __ ] party
people will see you hey hey yeah yeah
let's make it out yeah let's put it
together
that happens all the time how many times
a week does that happen
they be like man i don't [ __ ] with that
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying
that's just what it is right that has to
happen to you five six times
but i put like this out of every
20 people that do that right if i get
one or two
that live up to what they say that's
great i take those one and two i plug
them in
to all the other one and twos and then i
create my team like that
it takes time to create a team in this
industry of course
that's real [ __ ] so you said earlier
you like to call a spade a spade so why
why did you feel the need to
to call out the way you did because like
for instance right
i look at six nine and i like okay you
dis you violated did this did that right
that's it right i'm not pressing who's
promoting six nine
i'm not pressing academics it's all you
know popping up on clubhouse and [ __ ]
like
you know because of [ __ ] like
you you know supporting this this this
you need to be in all this so they
definitely pressed them i'm not doing
i'm not doing all that right
okay you asked me get dude violated some
of them people are my comrades that's in
jail
you know what i'm saying shout out to
nuke that you know some of them do just
is i know personally but i'm never it's
never came out my mouth that it's on
when we catch your [ __ ] ass is
what it's gonna be right
i hate to say it six nine made history
again
because the prey pulled up on the
predator
and that's unheard of see usually the
predator controls the narrative
because he can talk that [ __ ] and deep
down inside he know he ain't gonna do
nothing right so what he does is if he
know his prey
is over there he just don't go over
there he stays away from him
so it's never a situation in this
situation
the prey pulled up on the predator and
how that's supposed to work
once you didn't set the stage and say
it's home you're going to dress up
[ __ ] when they see you
when they pull up on you right hey bro
with sick skinheads they pulled up on
being called me
and you [ __ ] laid them out i could
have said always six of them
and i stayed in the car got on you know
what a lot of people would have said
oh what do y'all expect it's six i'm
gonna see the rules
and code of the streets where i come
from whether
it's in favor or not in favor you gotta
handle your business
win lose a draw it's been a situation
where it's more of us
than them it's been situation where it's
even steven it's been situation was
it's me by myself i have to remain who
i'm supposed to be
so on the flip side when that man pulled
up
with his squad and let's let's for the
note
little dude ain't no house arrest no
more there's no police with that dude
i know a few of them dudes they're not
police right and you in florida
to stand your ground stand your ground
in fact we all know about that right
so at the end of the day the whole
situation people saying oh me going go
to jail hey look check this out
if you are worried about it concerning
yourself what
jail or or or in the backlash of it
then don't speak on it don't involve
yourself to that capacity
to where you pressing this dude and
pressing people around this dude
say the dudes are right i don't agree
with the [ __ ] he did and keep it moving
but you set the stage to where it's
shown when meek and game was going at it
right
when we bumped it's home
they said yo y'all can't do that show in
philly uh we be there at seven o'clock
two bus lows five run the cars deep well
it's gonna be whatever it's gonna be
and we went and had a cheese stick
afterwards
we see you it's sown ain't no talking
ain't none of that
this is the irrational rules we live by
right so you can't oh okay today and a
good day cause i might get caught
nah [ __ ] this is what this is
you you you charlie saying if you sign
up for this yeah you
you gotta take what come with that okay
now look it's here
his squad pull up it ain't no talking
get off
that's it that's how they go if you got
a squad with you they ain't gonna move
with you
then maybe you know other people change
that up because
they had no problem doing that to
suffocate off on safari
they chase that man down like a dog and
he ain't dead no instagram [ __ ]
he ain't saying he called you no [ __ ]
he ain't called you nothing
you know [ __ ] you took his woman are you
mad at him
mm-hmm you know what i'm saying yeah so
you had no problem
you know you can't be i call it
selective politicking
you want to pick and choose when you
want to do this to do this and do that
nah so let me ask you this um devil's
advocate
let's say meeks evolved as a as a
professional as a
as a human as a nation supposed to
represent that you know what i'm saying
it's supposed to represent that okay for
instance uh
uh uh what's my man my sign yeah yeah my
son speaks strongly against six nine
he's a [ __ ] rat
boy my son going to a club he don't
wanna hear the music
all that but you never heard my sign say
when i catch this little [ __ ]
that's what this
is cause my son is a community leader
now like you know what i'm saying but he
a real street [ __ ] 100
yeah but he used to be signed again so
if my sign was to walk in the same
building room
nine in i'm not expecting my sign to do
[ __ ]
you're saying unless that man becomes a
threat because man put that out there
put that out that you say this is what
it is yeah i got you
like like he put it out to your whack i
want i want you to pull up on me okay
cool hold them words
because see i'm not six knots i'm gonna
force you to get down
you're gonna have to get down if that's
what it is your squad your team
your whatever it is because me you said
that now you said that all i did
was address your actions with this kid
right you chose to get away from that
and said well you know and i've seen you
meet like two three times
i've seen you you know you called me to
squash the game beef i'll let you in
game do that
right right you know what i mean game
was a gentleman about it he said look
i'm going a different way in my life i
just got out
i don't want to be beefing with nobody
gangsta we said i ain't no bully homie
if that's your energy is cool keep my
name out your mouth keep
and he kept it moving i've seen you two
three times bt weekend you shook my hand
you making comments about nipsey my
[ __ ] that's kind you're a philly dude
man i'm saying i don't know what you
talking about the nipsy [ __ ] right
but i've seen you since the nipsy [ __ ]
right face to face all you had to do and
anybody know
all you got to do is show me any signs
of aggression say what you're going to
say
right and we're going to get to it i got
attorneys and bail bondsmen
and my wife they've been with me 30
years she know what to do i'm gonna go
in there go to sleep do a couple
push-ups
come home but then that's what that is
right but you know
don't put that out there that that's
what it is and then when it comes at you
you go to talking about oh you're trying
to send me to jail well you know what
that's what happens when you agitate
violence and disrespecting anybody rat
no rat gay not gay punk no punk if you
disrespect somebody
in the back of your head you gotta
expect something might happen
even if they don't commit to act the
bags make things happen
and it's just real [ __ ] so if you are a
advocate of
non-violence then you shouldn't speak
that into the world you shouldn't even
be addressing it right right don't even
say nothing about
it yeah cause ultimately it's a bunch of
new york dudes that's in jail
that ain't philly business that's facts
and that's all that was you know he
turned into a personal thing
i just called a spade a spade yeah i
mean i think that um
you know meek obviously i think
you know he wants to control the
narrative and he wanted
he wants the rules to be his rules but
me you ain't you've been in the game
like you like you're like 33 years 34
years old bro
you ain't you ain't nobody to dictate
and control the rules that been there
before you
well i was going to say i think some
people might say well like whack why
even
call me out in that because you could
just you know what i started to see
people started to say oh because of who
meek is you know
he didn't no no no no no let me remind
everybody
press play on this song he didn't kill
300 [ __ ] in first 10 verses
talking you know that that's what it is
you at this kid you
attacking people around this kid and if
that's what you want to do i respect it
but that kid came out you supposed to
handle your business
i would hope that from this point on
meek because of you know how what he's
saying he's an
advocate of peace and nonviolence don't
address [ __ ]
that be that brings violence let
somebody else do that
you know i mean look if you think of
like someone like jay-z right and the
way you ever hear
jay-z jay pivoted away i mean if you
listen to jay's early [ __ ] once jay
became
that guy his music in there even when
him and nas went at it
it was in the music you never heard
jay-z do interviews saying
when i catch nazi song right right right
right
you left it with music that was music
that's what that was the minute
you come away from music and go to
talking about what it's going to be
right then you you got you got to stand
up on that which is what meek did with
with with six nights yeah you know at
the end of the day i don't want to see
nothing look i had nothing personal
against me
nothing i didn't talk to dude on the
phone he didn't did music with chuck
since then
yeah yeah in my studio yeah right
mm-hmm real [ __ ] mm-hmm he didn't been
right there with us
but you know i'm a spade guy and all my
comrades know that
but you do something inside the
character and out of pocket i'm gonna
call you and i'm not gonna
my son can't do some [ __ ] i'm here to
tell you son that's some punk [ __ ] you
just did what you doing
that's my son i would say well that's my
son you know people are dead
they have opinion about everybody else
but soon as this they people they want
to kind of like sweep it under
that ain't how i move i'm gonna call it
spade a spade bro
you know what i'm saying you're doing
some [ __ ] [ __ ] you're doing some [ __ ]
[ __ ] you're doing some real [ __ ] you're
doing some real [ __ ]
and that's just what it is nothing
personal bro it's just
that's the politics of the situation
they broke you was talking that [ __ ]
dude pulled up on you it's you should
have went
well you you i think that the other
thing too is hey if you know my squad i
know let a [ __ ] pulled up on us
we're going we didn't had the samoans we
didn't have
all kind of [ __ ] pull up on us
it's going to be this your track record
is uh on video for years
that's just
it's just what it is i mean death road
days broke
like squads pulled up i swear to god uh
shout out to big faith from long beach
insanity it just came on
from doing like 10 15 years right we go
to the santa monica um new zealand after
party
day in there we rolled in we locked up
like wild bulls it was like 50 60 of us
ain't no it was police all kind of [ __ ]
security pulling guns y'all do what
y'all do
but we know it's on on site you know
what i'm saying i watch fade put in
major work
and he was on the other side of it i'm
watching faith knock [ __ ] out
that's with me i'm seeing it so i
respect the man's gangster whether he
with me or not
i'ma call a spade a spade but that's
what that is
nowadays we pull up they see us we see
them
it's all love there's no problems but
when you've been established it's a
problem in his own like that
when they come at you you got to deal
with it unfortunately
certain things come with that sometimes
it's death sometimes it's jail sometimes
you injure
you might win you might lose if not
don't [ __ ] with it leave it alone
do you think that um because you're
obviously a ceo
you're uh you're an executive you're one
of the most you know
successful independent [ __ ] in
this rap and i got a ged
straight up do you i was gonna say do
you think at sir what point in time do
you think
some of this [ __ ] is just beneath you
wack well you gotta understand by the
way it's entertaining cause i really
i do enjoy at times like your ig be very
entertaining i understand as long as i'm
in this music industry this music
industry
right and even the execs to tell you
right the zex is in the building
you don't see the umg execs and the sony
execs coming out here to the streets to
scout nobody
right they leave it up to people like me
to go scout them and then bring them
back to the building
right so it's just like you know
preparing for a trip
when you're going into the jungle right
um you know when
when can you change i've got to respect
the laws and the rules of the jungle not
the bear over there the snake over there
the lions over there
so for whack to say you know after all
these years
i've been a part of this thing well you
know what it's beneath me
i just mean the social media aspect well
you know
social media is like a culling book to
me i don't care about it
right you go pull up all the new artists
i signed they got a blue check
you know i got a blue chat that's why i
got them a blue check don't got a blue
check
i don't care about it like it's a
coloring book yeah they can shut that
[ __ ] down i was who i was before
[ __ ] social media you know we had to
have social media back can you imagine
we had social media backgrounds like
gaming 50 was beefing
or the death row time i think about it
all the time it was crazy so a lot of
these kids understand look we were doing
some other [ __ ] way before this [ __ ] so
it's like
but dude needed to be addressed and i
really think
on some real [ __ ] i really think i
helped him
become a better person because i think
in the near future
when things come up if it doesn't
directly involve
me he won't speak on it i think he's
going to leave that alone
which which again so you know i might
if you look at it another way you know i
might have did him a favor because he
might have put his nose in some other
[ __ ]
that led to some other [ __ ] right right
right that's fair
um talk about you know you
obviously for people who don't know um
you originally when you you got out of
jail
the first artist that you worked with uh
was
was the first one i worked directly with
my project that was ray j was ray j
that was was that around the sexy can i
era that was my project so that was like
peak ray j yeah that's me and me me
shaquille o'neal
and at that time suge knight said whack
you need to go rebuild
what i tore down get the new york plugs
right and that's when
i met k slay all-star weekend in vegas
and me and k
slate started politicking and we created
this movement called bridging the gap
go to youtube and pull it up you'll see
i would bring slay out here
take him to all the neighborhoods crips
and bloods both sides
and he would work with artists and then
i would send artists out there with them
and he would do their mixtapes put them
on the show g malone j-rock
k-dot um building a bridge from
coast to coast nipsey all that all them
dudes first time on new york radio was
wack situation with casella the drama
king right yeah he would take him out
there we'd do the thing with him and
then
slay us and artists out here he wanted
to do videos so we was
crossing over in each other's culture
making it safe again
so it was cool because at one time it
was on you know what i mean we get
caught off the island it was at us and
it was the same thing
what was that like oh 607 i was like i
met slate bottle five and then we did
this ray j project 0607
yeah k slay actually ann are that old
project
we leaked sexy cannot behind the labels
back listen k slay
is a i used to make a lot of your
bootleg cab that's how i got my name but
slang and mixtapes at the swap meet when
i was 17. man big brother
mentor teacher we argue we fuss fight we
do everything [ __ ] i live across the
street from him
and i just said in jersey i got a spot
out and respect to his
uh just relationships with the porn
[ __ ] because i would always see
all these straight stuff magazine all
the porn [ __ ] on the covers yeah
always on the shade 45 show that's like
yes
so but you know i gotta you know i do
this music thing because i feel like
that's a need for me here because
a lot of these kids is like nobody's
gonna run the field with him
well i feel like you obviously went from
ray j
um and then you know working with game
i feel like in the last four or five
years though you really hit your stride
as an executive
finding new talent yeah yeah yeah you
know because that's
you know ray j was already someone we
knew you know
when you came along now obviously he hit
the peak of his career with you
game already established name but you've
shown people that
that's like the shelf game was this was
this the gaffin era
no that year they tried the show game
it's right after you figured probably
bought the jesus piece there he owed him
another album and tried to put him on
the shelf
oh wow you know that's when we went to
miami and
cool and dre shout out to cool andre um
they opened up their studio for us for
like two months
he went in and started recording i just
i was in and out i was jumping on planes
and
getting releases here and doing this
here and doing that then
finding another situation here that's
where you've seen year the wolf came in
and right after year in the wolf i
dropped documentary two and two point
five to double c
remember year the wolf was obligation
through a negotiation that i had to do
to get him wasn't that more like a
compilation or was supposed to be right
i had to do that to release him
he put all his everything into the dock
2 and 2.5 so
gain was like in a uh he was in one of
those contracts with them near 10 years
and they tried to shelf him and i just
kind of used my resources
and who i was and what should taught me
to do to get him out of that
with that like when you say what should
have taught you to do this we think of
some of those should knight
antics that might have well you know i
don't think it was antidid you know i
think sure gets to um
the short end of the stick because the
the uh persona
but if you were to ask joe to see of use
the axe you know mary jay
of viewers asked the kid that did the uh
ice ice baby beat
about uh suge's business they'll tell
you
all he did was make the wrong right
you know what i mean suge turned 30
cents
meaning the album seller for ten dollars
and the artist is getting 30 cents
off the sale just crazy 230 percent
right he turned 30 cents which was the
old motown [ __ ] and all the old day [ __ ]
right
to 30 percent so now you're 30 cents and
it don't be a group
like the alcoholics ten cents a piece
now he turned that to three dollars
right right
so um and i've always seen sugar try to
deal with things the right way out the
box but unfortunately
um even in america has been proven
you know our world we come from in these
violence
that's what people respect yeah you know
what i mean i hate to say it you know
what i mean like if you're walking down
the street
you see a yard that says beware a dog
and then another yard with the gate open
and you didn't make a decision you going
to somebody's backyard the mere
daughter that dog back there says you're
going to go on it you're going to go
with the gate yeah you know what i'm
saying that's just the world we come
from
it's a reason why you know uh china
won't launch on us and we won't launch
on that we owe them people a lot of
money
you know that trillions of trillions of
dollars it's the threat
of the violence that could happen so you
know
um sometimes when you've exhausted
everything else
you know you got to go another way with
it and he only went there if you
force him to go there other than that he
was very protective of his family
and he was very protective of his
employees as well as his
one of his artists talking about game i
feel like somehow
in history game has ended up underrated
because when we think a game and his
consistency with
just putting out bodies of work that are
like front to back
i feel like part of it his fault part of
his nine
because game believe it or not
um he was in it for the passion of rap
the passion of being an advocate a voice
for the streets
he wasn't in it for the superstardom
right you know i bring game a deal
uh and he told me whack you had it your
way i'd be on every billboard every
goddamn
bus every motion picture man listen i
ain't that that's not what i want i want
to be able to go places even though
you know he's crazy as hell he still
gets up and moves around like he's
normal but
like bro he stood up stealing steven
spielberg twice
wow real [ __ ] like game never wanted
the superstardom he'll tell you that
like he never wanted that
like you know so if if he would have
wanted that
he could it's a lot of things that he
turned down
18 movie that was his role he was like
oh wow you know it was all kind of [ __ ]
that game
the the the shoe deal he walked away
from that they didn't walk away from him
wow
you know what i mean they're like man
you got to wear this [ __ ] every time on
stage like yo bro i'ma wear with the
game wanna wear
but i feel like wearing this i wear it
other than that i'm also chuck taylor
i'm gonna put these all-stars on my feet
right
so it was like game never you know
wanted that stardom
that super stardom like he didn't shut
me down millions of times
like [ __ ] that we do this that leads to
this at least that at least it is
he like dang while i won't let's let's
stick to the music let me go and make
another dope album
well let me do this to contribute to
that that now let me make another dope
out let me stay focused
on you know being a messenger to the
people from the streets so
that's what that was what is uh what's
the uh you know there's
there there's been all this discussion
over the years i remember you would put
50 and game together
and and that was the monster i remember
seeing that picture
and it was like yo this is great like i
just be thinking like how different
the history of our like three times
three times i got them together
um you know but my team out there bpe
team a dollar
um um relatives what was at the time was
50's head of security
brother named monster real solid dude
and through our relationship
i was able to have conversation with 50
in our backyard and uh
i kind of it was crazy because i went to
50. we was in that with the aods over
there on monday night yeah yeah and uh
diamonds we're in there 50 in there and
um
gang said y'all need to holler at 50.
you know once you tell me you want to do
something he spoiled it you know i got
to make
it happen so i'll go over there come in
monster cleared up
holiday 50 trust me big game when i
holler at you like wax ain't the right
environment
you deep weed deep it's going to turn
into something i said now i'ma bring
game over here to you so you're going to
bring him over here just y'all say yeah
just us too
i said i'm going to stand behind you and
monster gonna stand behind game
and y'all do some funny [ __ ] you had a
disadvantage monster you what he said
i'm definitely woodies and that's when
you saw them
i think charisma shout out to charisma
was djing that night and they talked and
you know whatever they was talking about
and
shook hands and laughed and giggled a
little bit and then you know it was cool
yeah i just think like that's
one of the like like vivid memories in
hip-hop history like high school when
the documentary
like the first time i heard howie do was
like that's what one of my favorite
songs ever and i just
like like how different would hip hop
have been had that
conflict never happened definitely crazy
movie
you know game had his reasons and uh 50
had his reasons
and you know um some of it might have
been business some of it might have been
maybe some of the reasons of selfishness
and through reasons of ego
yeah you know i really think that um it
was a situation where it was teacher and
student
and i think out of the whole g-unit crew
and you know shout out to tony yeah yo
that's a real
comrade of mine i think game was a
a teacher in the making you know what i
mean
and if somebody is going to come out of
that shell you can't keep them there too
long and then
50 being the general minded guy he is he
run his [ __ ] with an iron fist
so i think it was a clash going on and
before 50 kind of realized it game kind
of scene that
it's this is going to restrict me right
right right i got it i got to get away
from this and
and and that's how that went you know
what i mean but nevertheless
um it both gave hip-hop the substance we
needed
because hey 300 bars are running 50 50
50 allowed that
collaboration to happen and then through
it all
you know what i mean um they was able as
men
you know to kind of like come back
together and show that that mutual
respect
do you think like the jimmy henchman
like element of that
dynamic like like like maybe added to
that divide a bit
well jimmy henchman was needed at the
time you know what i mean you got
these biggest anything you can be into
never
i always say the two biggest rappers of
all time
snoop that would that jimmy henchman
element was what gave
gamers edge because paul rue was gonna
stand behind him out here
on the west coast and then he had part
of his head security
uh bounty hunters two t's and bounty
hunters and uh
chief magic from 88 avalon so it was a
mixture of everything we represented out
here standing with him anyway right
so that jimmy henchman element kind of
gave game to edge like that extended
clip because jimmy hinchman
was who he was in new york right so now
you look up and jimmy henchman's
politics got game and a big-ass
billboard in the middle of south side
queens
right and game lands in new york because
he got to come to new york
jimmy henchman's squad is there to move
him around to protect him so
you know i don't jimmy jimmy did um
what he was supposed to do and he did
this [ __ ] well he did it great
you know and he stood with game um
as game still with him so i don't take
nothing from jimmy you know jimmy was a
solid dude
he got a situation himself over there
with some paperwork going on
and he gonna deal with that as he got to
deal with that but what he did for game
um jimmy was he did it right by him he
did right behind yo what up
taking a break in into the uh the
bootleg head podcast here
to tell you about our sponsor odd socks
man make sure you go tap in with
oddssoxoficial.com
look i got [ __ ] odd talks on right
now you know what i'm saying got the
macho man randy savages
you know uh look they got the most
comfortable socks i ever put on my feet
not only that but they got the crazy
licenses they got the wwe
how about these scarface joints these
joints are crazy man so
scarface breaking bad um and their odd
socks basics line
these joints are so comfortable so go to
oddssocksofficial.com
use the keyword bootleg cav save 20 at
checkout
plus they just dropped underwear on them
plus they just dropped them slippers
and they got the mass
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
cab at checkout save 20
off [ __ ] odd sucks i i it's funny
because there was this big uproar about
people being mad that game said that he
thinks he's the greatest
rapper ever come out of compton i'm like
he's supposed to say that like
like well because he was on he was on
clubhouse and and and what he's
what he said about like yo i'm the
hardest to ever come out of confidence
i'm gonna tell you listen
i'm gonna kind of give you some insight
on that right because first thing people
gonna think is
uh uh kendrick lamar well i personally
think kendrick
as from and i think i think games right
there
i'm gonna tell y'all but game should say
that right i'm gonna tell you why he
says that
before it was a kendrick lamar was a
k-dot right
the kid k-dot now we go back to the game
50 situation mm-hmm
was a student of games no i didn't took
him on tour
lax store anybody knew who he was and
all this right now extort was nipsy
j-rock [ __ ] up kate out as humble as
he is
he probably would never answer the
question because i really think
kdot is in a lane of his own a mountain
of his own you're talking
two different type of rappers right kdot
is a legend
my book is coming out the west coast and
he's still got a whole lot of life in
him for sure shout out to tdd top dog in
the whole family over there
but game is always um
he's like like you won't catch you can't
get top dog to say
i'm a bigger record exacting sugar night
and he's moved some numbers right
because
suge knight was a teacher to us all
he's somebody we watched that we talked
to that we consoled it right
as big as top dog is he won't say that
right and he got some real stats that he
can stand on
fast so when it comes to game when he
sees kendrick no matter how big he get
it's kind of like
my son my son taller than me getting
bigger than me
that's still my son i'mma respect him
because he's my son he's a product of me
not to say gang built kendrick
but he was a a vital tool
in the growth of kendrick well i mean i
i remember that
that moment that moment when on stage
when
kendrick officially got past the torch
when kendrick crystal i didn't even have
to do that that was a big moment
but listen snoop dead stoop already he's
can't first of course
you know he ain't he can rap don't wrap
his icon right
cube everybody there at the time game
was still grinding
yeah but game did that because
this is one of his mans you know what
i'm saying hey i want to see you grow
right you know i mean so he's never
going to put himself
behind kendrick and i don't think
kendrick will ever put himself
ahead of the game i think it's really a
mutual respect for some
to the teacher's student thing to you
know the big homie lil homie type
type situation as if i don't think
kendrick will ever talk down on j-rock
of course not yeah cause he was once j
rock's height man now we look at numbers
we'll say oh [ __ ] kendricks and j
rock right but without that j-rock
element well j-rock is the first guy
to kick the whole [ __ ] off yeah without
that j-rock element
right they would there wouldn't have
been
that initial seating for nurturing of
kendrick lamar
you know what i'm saying so with certain
things that people are just not going to
say
whack i want you know history behind it
i look up to you in a lot of different
ways but i
i i know when it comes to finances
investing certain types of um
financial literacy things that you're
very good with
um you know i you would explain to me
something
kind of like a life hack how to use your
credit and your and credit cards
to help oh yeah i was giving you the
american express
you was giving me some game i wanted i
thought that that was it could you share
that with everybody because i feel like
it's
a lot of people right something super
practical people i tell a lot of people
the creditors is kind of like
they want to put you in a situation that
you can't get out of right
so you got to know how to manipulate
them right and first and foremost
let me say shout out to my my financial
advisor who has enhanced my intelligence
uh travis wilson tried for the stars on
instagram
that's my financial guy he's great with
numbers he's
had he's had he's enhanced everything
that i've known times a million right
but like if you got credit cards right
you got a card here and it's
you know five thousand dollars right and
you got five thousand dollars of bills
right
i'm gonna tell you pay your bills with
your credit card right
and then the money that you was gonna
use from your bank account pay your
credit card back so what the creditor is
going to say is
oh [ __ ] okay increasing your 10. right
pay the same five and keep doing it
you'll look up i got credit cards in my
pocket right now
i can literally go buy a rolls royce off
right now no problem disrespect
because everything i do instead of using
my
primary bank account right i use the
credit card and i put the money back on
the bank account
and you build credit until all my cash
is in the streets
i'm gonna keep it real with you this is
the way i think in my pocket i probably
got about four or five millions of
credit cards right
that if i want to today i can go pull
that cash down
right so i think business and i think
street
[ __ ] get weird to get funny i can
liquidate and get on whatever you gonna
put on my credit is cool
because if it's that bad when they catch
me it ain't gonna matter anyway right
right if it's that bad
and i can't use the credit cards because
that's a paper trail
but i can work off this cash so all my
street guys y'all y'all take and keep
that in effect right but
uh and then keep your keep your credit
at like a 25
utilization yeah if you got a thousand
dollar limit you know don't never pay it
off
pay it down to 250. you know what i mean
because that would help your credit
score you know and then real estate man
you know real estate
is always great always invest in real
estate um don't be scared to buy real
estate because the down payment is like
it's like a savings account
it's still there so i sort of try to
tell people like people who don't
understand like they'll be like man
like i always tell people to look at
real estate
not even one that you live in but but
just look at it as as your bank
instead of keeping the banking you know
your checking account it's in that crib
you can pull that out at any time
only probably the best part about it is
you get positive cash flow when homes
voted i remember i didn't paid 110 000.
i go check they worth six seven hundred
thousand dollars
how many houses do you own i mean or or
you know if you don't right now
i'm down to like 13.
i used to be like 23. i liquidated when
the oa [ __ ] hit
of course got off a few of them but um
you know real estate is good
land is good too as well of course
sometimes you can go to the city hall
and then look at the 10-year projection
and they'll tell you we're looking to do
a walmart here
shopping center here and it's like empty
land go by the land and get in the way
have you how how yeah they you know
you're getting away because you're
around it
that's some real [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying how much um like you know
when it comes to just being a source of
knowledge for guys like blue face
i know because i remember uh the first
time i met blueface i think
you and your wife were taking him to
look at houses like the day but i
brought i made sure blueface was a
homeowner the first 60 days he was
signed to me
he had a 430 fighter score got his
credit up me and uh
travis about the 727 30. he brought his
first home in his name his aim only no
co-signage
he played you know million five or so
for it
you know what i mean and then seven
eight months later
um tax issues so i wouldn't put into
another home
or another home you know i only paid
like a million two for that so
you know i'm gonna make sure my artists
are all homeowners i brought him his
first car
of course me and birdman did that you
know what i mean so he'd have to go in
his pocket
you know the first watches and rings you
know i do those things for my artists
because i want to see him win
is there ever an instance because you
know there's there's sometimes with
rappers
there's tax issues or there's legal [ __ ]
where
you've stepped in and been like yo it's
in my name
so you're safe because you know i feel
like there's well i
always protect my artists nothing's ever
in their name anyway
you know what i mean i don't even paint
them in their name first thing i do when
i sign them was i
buy them a court put it in your name i
set up a corporation i hear
this is all in the llc they can't touch
it it's theirs but i've never paid any
more
as direct i've always paid a corporation
i set that up for them so
um i'm i'm always teaching my artists
you know
how to protect themselves and i'm
setting them up yeah i think it's a game
people need because you know
medical like when i signed blueface
medical insurance uh
you know life insurance all these things
is things that i went out and made sure
that that he had you know life insurance
and his car insurances and make sure he
was
he was uh protected that's just what i
do because it's kind of like a you know
a father thing with me too as well you
know i want to see
everything and anything around me win
i'm gonna get old one day i'm gonna need
somebody to push that wheelchair a block
or two every now and then
you know what i mean and i want people
to remember you know i'ma overdue before
i underdo
um so i live in the valley i live kind
of sun valley essentially
been to pacoima a bunch to get great
mexican food
um i i think that can you kind of break
down
the difference between coming up in the
valley
because i feel like the valley is kind
of like la's kind of like step brother
what
what a valley you guys you got the
valley right and you got
you know you got those 210 babies right
you got pacoima
you got it there's like panoramic city
yeah and all around here right then you
have like william hills and chassworth
and all that right
i never even knew how to get over there
until i was like 21.
right right anything pretty much cross
rosco on the 405
and then you know that 118 that michelle
on up to glen oaks boulevard on around
the highest one or 210
that's kind of our pocket if you go over
there you'll find about four or five
projects
you know what i mean if i blindfold you
and took you from south central and took
the blindfold off when i got you to the
coin
you wouldn't know the difference listen
i went when i first when i first moved
out here i went to buy something off
offer up
and i had no idea about like like i was
like went to pakoyama and i was like oh
[ __ ]
it's real though the only difference is
when you're dealing with south central
compton watson la is that the about the
gangs right there's more gangs in these
areas
right so um do the politics ever cross
crossed
it's a little more dangerous for us now
today because
we're pretty much the only black gang
over there and with all the racial
tension
we're surrounded by hispanic gangs right
so now
that's the internal beast when i grew up
we shared the projects together you know
i mean we wouldn't let the
uh uh enemies get in through the through
the back and they wouldn't let the crips
come through through the front
right now it's kind of like that
generation now they're at each other's
throats so
um that's the difference between when
you're dealing with the greater south
central watch inglewood
their gangs are more it's more of them
you know you go across the street you
enemy across the street
and this is this and that we kind of had
the liberty of controlling our ship out
there
and even that was a problem when i heard
because
the drug trade was so great people
coming out there trying to take over
blocks so now we going at it
with gangs from l.a and they didn't know
we was there until they found out
you know y'all got to get up out of here
and then there's like tahunga and
sunderland which is where the bunch of
the biker gangs and [ __ ] got a lot of
white people [ __ ] hell hey hell's
angels and [ __ ] those angels and [ __ ]
like that's a whole another element
that we had to deal with as kids because
boy they catch you slipping late night
it was gonna be a situation
but then you had once you got to
chatsworth canoga park
um and even parts of canoga park is
greyers because you got a lot of
hispanic gangs over there
woodland hill i didn't know what the
[ __ ] calabasas was
until like 2008. that's some real [ __ ]
i didn't know what that [ __ ] was we
didn't go over there so when you hear
valley
people think to paying them all and all
that because they come in and they go
left they go on that 101.
i think it's like that strip it's like
sun valley pacoima san fernando
sylmar panorama city because the valley
is
all the valley is if you come on the 405
freeway right you notice when you get to
the top and you start coming down
the valley is just a city that's
surrounded by the mountains yep
that's all it is by definition if you
sit in l.a and look as far as you can
see you won't see no mountains
true so it's kind of like even that san
gabriel valley area uh
pasadena you know the cities are
surrounded by by mountains so
that's really all it is but we got our
own little pocket over there you know
it's been there
um 40-something years the way we've been
into it you know a lot of people from
l.a
and from down south migrated that way
because it was farm country back then
and then it just like any place else it
turns in with a turn you look at you did
a research on cops yeah george bush laid
a cop
that shit's crazy i didn't know george
bush what i'm saying i know it started
off as a subject
we didn't move out to all the black star
company right so
that's what it is um talk to me because
you know i think that
you've been uh you know i we've had a
very
interesting last four or five years in
our country as far as just
racial tension relations um
i think you know trump being president
magnified a lot of stuff that was
already there
big homie was in office um right
and you recently had a situation where
you knocked two [ __ ] out on
video i mean but you know that's like
i wake up every day of my life expecting
something to go wrong
i prepare for the worst i hope for the
best to prepare for the work so it's
like
you know that's why i tell our people
like man there's some good people in
this world there's some crazy ass people
in this world
you know some people over there came
back from the ward is you know gone it's
some it's you know
believe it or not arnold schwarzenegger
did away with long-term
um mental health care a lot of these
people at the end of these freeways in
these parking lots
they could really get away with murder
right they gonna lock him over 48 hours
and let them go
so you know it's not even just a gang
element with me it's just a worldly
element that we live in
because you never know if you're going
to be in a restaurant dude go stand we
now try to lower
the movie start shooting so you got to
really pay attention you can't live in a
world that we live in
happy go lucky it's always some [ __ ]
going on but it's a drunk driver
whether it's a kid running out what
happened that day though where
i was in line [ __ ] you know i was
trying to give me a damn blt with
avocado
seasoned fries and raspberry iced tea
okay okay
and little dude was behind me you know
they smoked rubbers in these little
dodge
chargers the challenger cards so i kind
of leaned out i
could i don't want you lose control of
your car he was a skinhead dude
too but he was cool he like all right
cool no problem
two dudes on the pickup said mind you
been this [ __ ]
now once again watch this back to the
meek mill situation
it's five six seven in the parking lot i
could
have said it was six of them and i was
wanting me
so i left nah the politics i come from
they just so happened to catch me on the
day that i'm by myself
i gotta get out this is what this
is i could have pulled out in the world
would have never known those white dudes
ain't on social media they probably know
who i was
right but the politics embedded in me
i gotta get out however it turned out
i don't know they got knives on them
guns i don't know what they got on them
i didn't even realize it was three four
more over there in the corner and you
seen them walk up mm-hmm you know what
i'm saying so it was kind of and even
with that i was one of them on the
defense thing i couldn't really
attack like i wanted to because i saw
them walking up so i had to get back to
the vehicle
you know in case she went somewhere else
right so um
that's just what it is bro and you know
i
first want to tell you kids don't gang
bang
right it's some irrational [ __ ] that it
won't get you nowhere
there's no retirement plan you know what
i mean uh your homeboy is gonna hate on
you
when you go to jail they're gonna tell
your girlfriend about your other broad
and they're going to be at her too and
some i'm going to tell on you and all
that
right uh be a civilian be able to live
life the worldly way
be able to say you know what let me pull
off you know what let me go make a
report
that's the peaceful way because this
[ __ ] that we under is irrational it's
unreasonable
and it's dangerous and i don't wish it
on nobody
but it's like this is you this is it's
just what it is with me i chose it so i
got to stand in it
you know people say whack man you know
you you this age and you steal power
rule man i've never seen a christian
retirement
no this ain't no that's not a funny game
thing to me this [ __ ] for real this is
this is this is my way of life hey man
you know what i really
admire about you is the relationship you
got with your wife oh that's 30 years
i think that uh you know i i i've never
seen any i just
you know she's like your partner bro
yeah she's the opposite of me but she is
me
and she deals with all the whack [ __ ]
she's my she she's with me
she didn't been with me since we've been
14 bro she just seen some [ __ ]
she was with me when i earned the name
whack you know whacking my age meant
some other [ __ ]
today it means what it means you know
what i mean you had to earn that name
right yeah as a kid it was like you
whack a [ __ ] you know yeah
you know what i'm saying so it's a
little so yeah she's my balance
yeah like like how important is that to
have to you know because i
my wife is a man a woman like me i'd be
up on alcatraz
yeah she's my balance she she's gonna
talk some sense she's gonna give me
another way of looking at it
you know she's not scared of me she
understands me you know what i mean so
it's like
and you need that and then you
definitely want somebody that
you feel you can't live without so
that's what kind of controls
that anger because any real og that come
up banging in these streaks
all of us have an anger problem that's
what fuels
the viciousness you know what i'm saying
so you need something that
to think about whether it's her the
children yeah yeah you know what i mean
things like that you got to have
something to think about to
to bring you down i mean she's my
motivation man she you know she's my
biggest fan she cheers me on
um you know she lets me know how smart
she thinks i am you know men need that
we need that encouragement
also too like she takes a lot off your
plate like she's uh she does all that
she does all the time she does a lot i
initiate my clothes all the middle work
all the
all the flight booking the the producer
agreements the studio time booking
all that she controls so i can pass it
and then go on to the next one
so your label um 100 entertainment one
hundred entertainment cash money west
cash money weighs bird man i'm vp of
that 100
entertainment i'm actually running two
labels at the same time yeah you got
cash money west
100 entertainment so uh coyote
coyote true car flash gotti
all those are up under 100 entertainment
blue faces on cash money west side
face cash money it was originally savvy
third and blueface
um i got a few artists i'm just waiting
to see what birdman want to do because
he gets the first pick of whatever it is
that's just what that is kiddo curry out
of chicago
um and probably um just mikey probably
gonna end up on the cash money on west
side so i'm just waiting on birdman to
give me the green light on that
so uh what is what do you look for man
like like when it comes to talent when
it comes to an artist like you know what
what are the qualities that
you look for true car was stood out to
me was um i thought it was from the
south
but it's from watts some watts and you
know you got to respect
the south got the torch right now a lot
of people from new york and l.a don't
want to admit it but the south got the
torch right they've been having their
troops
they've been having detroit about 20
years you know about 15 years ago
15 20 man you know so you know he was
different you know what i mean uh you
know they got this auto-tune sound thing
going on it
it's saying the same thing just in the
auto-tune way so you can find that adam
a dozen he was different
and i respected the fact that actually
we could bring him in if you want to
now if you uh i respected the fact that
he
was grew up in watts and and lived
um he's actually off the street they
called it a dime block 110th
which is not actually inside the
projects but the outer streets outside
the projects
but i respected the fact that he didn't
gang bang
you grow up around it his family's
around it but he's not from bounty
hunters
right everybody around him is but he's
not and i respected that
you know what i mean so i kind of look
at and his work ethic is crazy like i've
never owned a studio i'll go book one
out block one out
he running so hard i had to actually go
kill the studio shout out to stat quote
that's my bro man you know what i mean
stack quote and dj
they blessed me with my with my
situation i got over there and let me
take over and just
put it together how i wanted to you know
i mean society's that quote
so he um his work ethic like he minds me
a game
game going knock out four or five joints
tonight right right right right right
and they was in there last night and it
was crazy because
i'm hearing this game snoop oh you know
you're on the hook we just did it last
night
okay we got a true call on the hood
that's going to be on the um evolution
of banging on wax
is that going to be the compilation you
were telling me about with asia and ty
yeah asian ty dolla's got a name got a
big record the singles bloods crips
power rule with mazzy ot genesis game
blue face on that that's coming out
through um uh
i'm working that through three one nine
cash money on the distribution so you
said evolution of banging on wax people
don't remember that that was the crips
and bloods
was crips on one side bloods on one side
which was a red rump
um and um you know big y and um
stretch they did that situation but the
chris was dissing the bloods on one side
bloods was just in the crips on one side
since then we've kind of evolved to
where this blood and [ __ ] thing has went
across the united states and
how we're doing it is we're making sure
everybody got our understanding
especially in this music industry to
minimize the violence
so the evolution side of it which uh
came from wacko from west side parole
142nd street um his whole thing was to
let's show the evolution of it to where
now we got bloods and crips on the same
songs
doing great music together getting along
the evolution of it so we promoted the
[ __ ] back then
[ __ ] these [ __ ] kill these [ __ ] 25
years later
we still here standing hey listen our
politics are across
i land on your block you're in my city
you're my studios
it's all love it's cool vice versa so
that's what that is
that song all right so look you you
actually you've been busy
yeah yeah working working for sophie so
we got one coming this week what's up
what's up we had to do it for the city
so crazy yeah
yeah you you got some big features
obviously the richer kid records out the
reach
yeah you told me it's got the old school
sample on it right we took games let's
ride and flipped it you know clipped it
right
out of the game did that and scott
stores came and touched it for us
oh yeah shout out to storage so hey
when this guy originally calls you or
like how did y'all how did you find him
and how did the initial conversation
blue face told me wanted to do a remix
on the song
and uh he said can you find him this is
his name sent me his instagram i dm'd
him
and you know you know some people wake
up say dm for me don't know how to take
that [ __ ] right so i dm'd him and um
he sent me his number i called him i
told him what it was
um he pulled up in the studio blueface
knocked it out i said look whoever you
working with
i asked him who he was signed to he said
nobody and
asked him where he was from he said
watch and grow up around the [ __ ] and
gardens
so first thing got my mouth respect for
my brother top dog i'm like
have you reached out to top dog in tde
right so he was like he was trying to
get some
you know things that way or whatever so
i said well i'ma call over there
so before that i told him i said look
whoever you're working with just tell
them we're doing you a favor
enhancing your music gonna let you use
blueface platform yeah it's all love
no strings attached right but i warned
him when you tell them you came in with
me
they're gonna feel some type of way and
they're gonna get different with you
and i think because i told him what was
gonna happen before it happened when it
happened
he called me back and said i need to
come talk to you and he pulled up on me
i was working in the studio on glendale
at the mint room
he said man as soon as i told him that
you know i was over here with you
everything changed i said well you know
you want to come over here and work you
can work
because what i like to do i let artists
come to my studio
use the studio for free two three months
whatever you want to do record
i want you to want to work with me i
don't force contracts over
i don't dank or bone in front of you if
you comfortable with me
then you can come to my office and then
we can map out what we want to do
and he'll tell you that he was over
there free fall
two three months i never no paperwork
never knew nothing
but he felt he was ready
because far as i'm concerned him being
able to come to my studio for those
eight hours and ten hours
he got more chance at life he ain't over
there on the block
ain't nothing happening to these kids so
i'm giving you an outlet someplace to go
whether you got any money or not
i'm gonna pay for the room anyways yeah
i got a couple rooms so
even if some kids just come to hang out
you know it's a it's better than them
being where
it's it's it's an outlet and you know
and i give them that because i feel like
hey i think that's another misconception
about you that you just kind of squashed
that like i think a lot of people look
at you as like
whack is this big so he out here leading
people right away
but i think you need to you know it's
good that you're promoting that because
i don't think people understand like the
[ __ ] you'd be doing for people
that we don't even know about you will
never find nobody that can say whack
supervise or orchestrate any kid
getting put on a street game i learned
at an early age
i was sent to the penitentiary at 16
solid that
that this [ __ ] is some [ __ ] but i
was too so far it's too late
it was what it was so i told myself i'm
never gonna put this on
nobody else's child because i know what
this is i believe what you put in the
universe
is gonna come back i had i knew i had a
son on the way and you know i'm not
gonna
do this to somebody then one day
something happened to mine because of
what i orchestrated over here so
they all tell you i got all kinds of
[ __ ] in my building it be [ __ ] my
building ain't supposed to be in the
build at the same time
like who they killing right now and they
blocks but they right here
three four different neighborhoods
getting along so now
when they see each other you know i mean
maybe they'll let each other live
even if wax not there because through
wac they develop a relationship
which is great yeah exactly well look
wack i know you i know you were supposed
to get out here at three o'clock we're
running late on yeah i gotta go
i got daddy duties i gotta take back
orders um but you know
we got truecar he coming blueface is
coming
um games coming i got a 30 for 30
playlist
type album that we're releasing um
shared true car
based on the true story it's coming up
soon
we got to do a free style so i told him
[Music]
yeah i ain't seen him right nothing yet
he comes
um but like you know shout out to
everybody that been there my man jr
running my marketing e1
that's been also the diapers you got
incredible diapers incredible diapers
yeah they launch into june
um the only minority owned uh shot nick
cannon
in the universe um nick cannon um yo
nick cannon gonna need those diapers too
my man is out here populated
nick said he's trying to have tin he's
getting down for sure you know he
allowed me to use his name
i was trying to come up with a name and
i was in a rut and i was like
you know uh credible diapers i like the
ring of it so i called it
perfect you're like what go ahead do
your thing he wouldn't even take no
money from me but i still wrote it up
he gave him gave him his percentage he
hasn't had to do anything i haven't
asked him for no funding and that you
know i'm pretty sure when it comes time
to marketing promoting yeah he'd
definitely be there for me but
you know um definitely you know we're
moving things in other ways and
to empower ourselves so we don't need
other people to do the things that we do
in music backs well look appreciate you
pulling up wack it's about time man
yeah definitely and we're gonna have i i
talked to uh to
uh the coyote dudes because they've been
them them dudes can rap shout out
like a rap rap so i've been talking to
them about pulling up we're going to do
a freestyle with them do a freestyle
with you and
and um boom 100 entertainment 100
when we go on there yeah boom
west up